[Musique]
et moi les angles idole
on a un nouveau qui arrive dépêchez vous
faut l'attraper arrivée imminente d'une
nouvelle idole ou l autre groupe des
pâtes pendant d'une mère mon vieux des
pins et 103 je vais l'avoir wheeler
année sur
[Musique]
mais ça va prendre le même chemin que
j'ai été choisi pour aller dans le grand
monde bienvenue à orly-ville la mise
quel est ton nom
coucou plein temps comme tête d'un
génial on adore les noms littéraux tu
n'es pas d'accord ce sera bien
alors vous voulez vraiment vous
entraîner pour le grand monde
tu parles et on va tous trouvé un enfant
pma nous a aimés vous savez que lou va
tout faire pour vous faire échouer
pas vrai moi j à l'o2 luis qu'il a de
bonnes intentions mais il a aussi
parfois des préjugés qui croit tout de
même sans ces critiques constructives
aucun d'entre nous on irait très loin
alors rester dans ses bonnes grâces cool
des lunettes
j'en ai toujours voulu oui moi je me
sens plus brillants et les plus
intelligents robredo dabul donne
je vous en prie on est désolé ne dit
rien aux autres d'accord et surtout pas
alou beaucoup de poupées ont des
lunettes à hoggy ville même style cinq
vieux ici c'est l'institut de la
perfection et les poupées parfaite ont
une vue parfaite non et moi qui croyais
que moxxi avaient la vie dure
un afa pour chaque poupée une poupée
pour chaque enfant se retrouveront le et
l'autre quand le destin leur sourira qui
sait comment ça leur arrive c'est
rarement dans les lire la vie choisira
leçon momar aujourd'hui sera l'air grave
chou you debout moxxi bonjour pegi je
suis le pays depuis des heures
aujourd'hui pour être le grand show ça
lui bondi de quoi tu as l'air en cette
journée courte sur pattes grand sourire
bel bat écarté le rose en fait un petit
trou pour papeete et whaou étaient
vraiment à croquer
[Applaudissements]
c'est espère aller au grand tu sais quoi
[Musique]
gagne ton écoute moi on t'aura pas la
moindre chance le soin d'expliquer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chaque année des millions de jouets sont
créés est parfaitement conçu pour
apporter du bonheur aux enfants du monde
entier
mais qu'arrive-t-il aux joueurs qui ne
sont pas parfaits
erreur
ja rule a privé le jour au début non des
fonds nous rendent unique
ça vaut la peine qu'on se batte pour toi
est ce que tu crois vraiment que deux
petites bandes de poupées moche à la
moindre chance ici tout le monde est
prêt
avenue à l'institut de la perfection où
seuls les meilleurs se tiendront le
souhait de l'enfant
[Musique]
je ne sais pas encore mais t'as vu
courtois c'est quoi ton nom peut-être
plâtre j'adore les noms les terreaux tu
n'es pas d'accord ce sera bien
ouais je t'assure